all right guys morning everyone we are
starting today our live session that is
gonna be lasting for three hours still
from panama guys uh we are monday the
market is about to open in 10 minutes so
as usual i'm gonna start with
um an analysis on amc gme i want to talk
today about hymc that is seeing some
volume coming here
after amc and sprott decided to buy some
shares in this company that is a gold
and silver mining company
i think i'm going to buy some shares
today at the open so we have nine
minutes left on hymc so let's start
right now i'm gonna start uh with amc
daily time frame
uh so here i'm gonna come back to that
because in nine minutes i don't have
time to make the full complete analysis
we're gonna see where are our support
levels where the resistance levels what
other scenarios that can happen so for
now the situation is
uh bam let's go on a logarithmic scale
the situation is that we're in the move
down and that we have the signal right
now with a volume increase a nice
breakout that this correction is over so
we can expect a move up to develop in
five waves as usual so in this
new move up hopefully
that can go very high we are at the very
beginning so this is what we call a
first wave so it's not easy to say if
this first wave is complete or not
we reach 22 we can go i think maybe to
25 even maybe 30 in this first wave
without any pullback and then at some
point we're gonna have a pullback that
can happen maybe in one or two weeks and
this is going to be a very nice
opportunity to load some shares and
options especially as the volatile the
volatility will be lower so right now
the first resistance level is at 22 it's
the recent high we had last week the
next one is at 25 so let's see if we are
able to go back to this levels today
we are still bullish here of course as
you can see the volume is um is
increasing on the way up
we only have green candles every day was
a win last week guys so
um
so we are looking good and there is no
immediate signal of pulling back now let
me go quickly on hourly timeframe
and here we can see
that
we have some um the market is taking a
little pause which is once again good
and healthy
um
and we can see the volume slightly lower
the momentum decreasing a little bit but
the market is not making new highs so we
don't have any bearish divergence okay
we don't want to see the market making
new highs with lower volume lower
momentum so right now on the short term
i would say that the level to take is 21
if we are able to trade above 21 i think
we can push to 25
we have support on the
50-day moving average on the hourly time
frame the best i have for now at 19.7
then next report is at 18.7 so
roughly between 18.5 and 19.5 we have
some support we have resistance around
20 21 then 22 so this whole area is an
area of resistance right now if we're
able to push through that with volume 25
is the target on the short term then
once again we expect maybe a little put
back hey guys morning everyone
we expect a little pullback
that can happen maybe in a week or two
so once again i'm going to be there guys
with you to monitor that we don't want
to see strong volume ins uh in this
pullback if it happens maybe we're just
going to squeeze and push higher without
consolidating without correcting it's
possible as well it is just unlikely um
and then once again this pullback which
is which can be seen as a second wave
correction
that is here guys
okay
for now i'm starting to check the
scenarios i'm trying i'm using you know
eliot with theory once again to help me
kind of try to understand this um the
potential structure that can take this
move up and for now what i see is that
we didn't pull back at all uh since the
lows so at some point we're gonna take a
little break a little pause once again
which is healthy uh just like we're
doing in this move up as you can see we
have some small poses that happened and
i expect the same thing to happen on a
bigger time frame and once again this
would be a nice opportunity to reload
so um
i'm going to get back to that i want to
check quickly with you guys what is
happening on h y m c
so here is the chart
and the chart is telling us that for now
we see the volume kicking in we know
what happened here there was um
[Music]
at the market offering that has been
done on friday uh even it has started
even before but uh amc added some shares
um on friday and this is the reason why
we are about to open higher today i see
the pre-market at 170.
so around 30 higher
um so here what is
i think
uh interesting to have a look at is
bam bam bam
is okay when i check the option market
it starts to be animated it is not crazy
yet uh we have a total short interest
right now at 10 percent uh once again it
has started much higher so this is hymc
that i'm checking and as you can see as
the 15th um on
on the 15th of march we had
around 60 million outstanding shares
okay the equity float was 35 million
shares and so the short interest was 32
and this is the number that is
interesting then
we had some shares that were emitted amc
bought
some of them
so the short interest is right now at
seven percent but once again because
there are more shares
and i wonder if the
total number of short shares has
increased as well or not so i'm going to
have a look at that when the data is
going to be available for now it is not
but what i can see is that this seven
percent is probably undervalued i think
it is more than that because once again
the
number of shares has grown but um
we don't have the update yet on the
total number of short shares that maybe
has grown as well uh during the last two
weeks the data i'm having for the short
interest is the last available data as
15th of march
so we're gonna monitor that but we have
some short interest we are a bit in a
situation like amc was
back in the time so this is the reason
why
uh amc as a company decided to get some
shares here they're just betting on the
fact it has of course nothing to do with
their business depending on the fact
that uh there's gonna be some interest
growing in the stock after they
announced that they're getting in
massively they bought 22 percent um
a share of 22 percent of this company uh
and so right now you know they're just
betting that gold is going to go higher
silver is going to go higher and that
this company that is that was close to
be bankrupt will do better because
they're probably going to change a bit
the business model as well you know
they're giving them that they they are
injecting some cash uh and they're
counting on on new guys they're counting
on the social media to you know um
talk about the stock to talk about the
situation so i think that something
might happen here
uh i'm gonna buy some shares at the open
guys
because
i don't think a big downside and we have
definitely a big upside okay i don't
know how high we can go
as you can see we are still in the
downtrend here
uh so i technically i don't have any
signal i would have the signal around
250 something like that
so for now we are still in this
downtrend
but we definitely have a nice
consolidation that happened after the
first move-up that occurred when amc
announced
they're going to get involved in hymc
uh two weeks ago
so this constellation is a very nice uh
support area and it is around one to 120
140 so i don't think we can go really uh
lower than that for now so buying shares
at
168 let's see uh what price i can get
is i think very limited in in terms of
risk i'm not going to go very heavy i
think i'm going to go for um 300 shares
to start and then i'm going to increase
on the way up if i have a breakout and
if we go lower i can increase my
position as well so i'm going to do that
in one minute
okay amc is about to happen higher gme
as well i'm gonna of course an uh gmu
about flatish i'm gonna analyze that i'm
gonna show you as well the spread that
we have between amc and jme jme still
trading at the premium of around
20 guys
okay so i'm gonna try to grab some
uh
some h white nc shares
recap
hey scott what's up bro
yes feeling bullish
for now we don't have any bearish signs
okay so i'm grabbing 300 shares then
170
okay i'm done so i just bought some hymc
300 shares
okay guys so
let's have a look at gme
and then there are many things i want to
discuss with you guys we have a lot
of um of information on the market i'm
gonna of course talk about the global
market guys i'm gonna talk about the
volatility we have some nice move up on
bitcoin as well we're gonna discuss that
uh first
once again
up
sorry okay so first let's have a look at
gme so why is it coming here up okay
so jamie up two percent right now so we
are still in the same situation okay so
we have this massive triangle look at
that guys
okay
massive triangle um we are coming on the
major resistance which is at 160.
so let's see if we're able to take it we
have the 200 moving average 200 day
moving average that is coming at 165
guys so uh this is the major resistance
area so for now as you can see this move
is very strong it didn't take any breath
for now so i think that um
we still have
the bullish momentum with us clearly
let's go on a shorter timeframe to
have a better look at
what the price action dynamics can give
us here
so still the same thing we're looking
for information about volume about
momentum and about volatility we're
going to combine all of that and try to
um to try to know who is in control so
here of course booze and control but
what we are interested in is to know if
a pullback is about to happen or not if
yes at what levels where our support
where are our resistance levels so like
i said the major resistance is 160
around here
uh for the support
we can see that we have so we can use
just the previous laws and consolidation
so i think that
147 is a nice support that can be used
but once again this move has been quite
extended already so i think that the
best thing to do here
of course uh i mean
is to
wait a little bit
to see what the price action can give us
in terms of um pullback levels later
because once again i think that this is
only a first wave so just like for amc
so we can i'm back here daily time frame
okay this is the first wave as you can
see this is one move it has uh not taken
any pose for now
and even if we have a look at what
happened in the past
like here you can see that here we have
the same kind of move like up sixty
percent we had like one very bullish
week then the market took a little pause
squeezed higher pulled back here so even
if very strong moves up like here as
well bam we go to
from
40 to 180 then we get back here and move
higher again so in any move up we always
have this kind of um
you know ups and downs even if they
happen very quickly so here for now we
are we keep pushing higher
um so let's try to find how high this
first move up can go so to know that we
have a we have a different tools that we
can use
so let's uh
let's start to make once again
some illiot wave counting so we had one
two so i think the third wave is
complete we're doing something like that
guys okay this is the situation we are
having so this is the reason why i think
that right now uh it's better to wait
for more information if we push higher
for the fifth wave that's very good news
it means that the second wave pullback
will just happen higher uh but to me the
structure of what i'm seeing here is
suggesting that this first move up i
mean we are i think in the last wave of
this first move up which can still of
course go much higher last maybe a few
more days
but at some point we're gonna have a
pullback that would take place and i
think that this would be the best
opportunity to once again get options as
the volatility would be lower and buy
more shares
as well so here we can measure one plus
plus three and apply to the bottom of
the force because we have a nice
structure and this is telling us that uh
the usual ratios of the fifth wave are
61.8 percent which is at 172. so this
level would make
sense it is not very far from where we
are in terms of percentage we are
discussing about
ten percent
nine okay so i think that jimmy can push
nine ten percent higher maybe today
maybe tomorrow
for now we are still looking good but
jimmy is giving us some first
um weakness
in the price action the weakness i'm
seeing is that we are making new highs
on lower volume lower momentum so like i
said this is creating some bearish
divergences so we can of course push
higher in the bearish divergence but it
is just telling us that this is in line
with what we see in terms of um
counting the waves
which is that we are maybe coming at the
end of this first impulse that was a
beautiful impulse full of volume full of
volatility um and that is just
suggesting that at some point we're
gonna take a little pause and uh
probably pull back a little bit so let's
make some scenario let's try to see at
what levels we could put back let's
imagine we go to 170 which is i think a
very reasonable target
so in this situation
we can measure the potential first move
and uh the second waves are usually
going to the 30
38.2
retracement sometimes if they are very
shallow only 23.6 percent so we can we
will probably see again 135 or 115. so
for this very reason
uh
i mean at 187
is above that level so i think that it's
better to wait we're gonna see some uh
better opportunities to get in some
shares right now on the very short term
uh we can use again moving averages to
find some support areas but here
on the hourly timeframe as you can see
we don't have anything that is very
clear that is really telling us this is
the moving average that most traders are
using so we need to once again wait to
see more clearly
where are all the buyers located here we
can see here we have this one
uh bam bam bam some the 30 minutes time
frame the 50 period moving average
is still supporting the price very well
so here we might see a bullish reaction
so it is right now at 143 so we are for
now very far from that
um
so let's focus more on the resistance
areas i think that right now we're you
know developing in this kind of triangle
okay it's even a wedge pattern it's not
a triangle so the difference between a
triangle and a wedge is that a triangle
is a corrective pattern whereas a wedge
is
pushing in the direction of the trend so
here we are bullish and a wedge is going
higher we have a raising wedge that is
once again usually a pattern that we
find at the end of some strong moves
which is usually containing a lower
volume just like we're having right now
and a lower momentum as well as a lower
volatility so whenever i see this
pattern
i prefer to you know wait
uh to know if we're to break out above
the wedge upper band which is here at
around 160 again or below if we break
out below it means that the second wave
pullback is starting if we break out
above it means that we are squeezing and
that we can start to see some very very
strong moves happening because right now
the bears are all located between 160
and 170 so let's see if we're able to go
through these levels today
um
bam bam bam so i hope this is helping
you guys i'm here trying to give you the
different scenarios that can happen that
i see uh potentially happening that
happened before in the past so once
again
we are still in this first impulse that
is clearly showing that boost to back
control on the short term for sure
medium term and
soon long term for boost to take back
control in the long term we need to have
a clear breakout above this 160 level
and we are coming right at it today
okay so look at that guys i like what is
happening we are moving above this uh
triangle
upper band
that is not very clear once again
because we don't have that many
reactions so i think that uh this
triangle upper band
is
here
um can be adjusted but what we have very
clearly is a resistance at 160 and the
200-day moving average at 165. on top of
that we have the fib projections that
gave us
uh 172.
if i apply the usual ratio i measure one
plus three i apply to the bottom of the
fourth once again guys fibs are just
here to give us areas they are not
levels that are very precise they give
us areas so that we can look for some
real resistance levels or support levels
in this areas here the area is 170. so
what i'm getting from that is that the
everything between 160 170 is an area uh
where probably we have some bears
located maybe some profit taking that
gonna happen so if we're able to go
through that it means that we need a lot
of volume and it would be a very strong
signal uh sent once again to the market
so let's see if we're able to do that
today we're gonna monitor what is very
important is to see the volume that is
gonna be training uh today we are monday
the beginning of the week so uh let's
see what everybody wants to do the big
money players are here guys for sure
they're involved in this thread whenever
you see a big volume like that it is not
only retail investors it means that um
everybody is starting to look at gme
because they see the potential and this
is a good scenario for
this strong moves up to happen once
again without the big money players it
is very hard to
move a stock like that that is a big
market cap that thing around 20 billion
us dollars um
so yeah we need everyone to be in the
street and we have everyone so let's see
what decision usually those guys they
take some decisions over the weekend so
let's see if they still buying today
or not if they are not buying we can
still push higher but on low volume so
this is interesting to see and i think
that they're probably gonna you know do
the same kind of
um reasoning as i do which is that
for now we are
of course very bullish pushing higher
but at some point there would be some uh
the market will take a breath and then
this would be a very good opportunity to
reload once again the higher we go the
better it is because the cl the mo the
clearer it will be that
boost to back control on the long term
and then we're just going to adjust the
fib ratios that we are using to
find the potential pullback
area that could happen once again in a
week or two so we have time
um
and so we're going to adjust the
vibrations that we uh apply to this
first move to see where we can
potentially buy more next week or uh or
even before depends on when this happens
okay so 160 we are there guys indeed
it's a very important level so let's see
if we're able to once again go through
it amc is strong so let's go quickly
have a look at the spread between amc
and jme you guys know that this is
something i like to monitor so the
spread is here i don't know if you see
well yes i'm just going to compute it
bam so we were at 20 to 21
last week once again the spread was
mostly due to the fact
that uh okay so for now i don't have the
data so amc is traded is trading at
22 gme 160 papa
okay 17 percent so it's still
a very nice premium uh very
very yeah quite substantial premium that
gm is trading above amc so amc has
can catch up and we can see mcs catching
up today very nicely
so here let's see what we have guys okay
bam bam bam
okay so we are breaking out above this
uh
you know kind of
correction that we had here
so i'm on hourly timeframe so i don't
see the volume yet i'm gonna go on the
15 minutes time frame because the 50
minutes is complete and as we can see we
have a nice volume so this is it's not
complete yet we have two more minutes
guys on the 15 minutes time frame and
we're gonna have a complete volume bar
that is gonna be formed and this is a
very good comparison that we can make
with what happened last week so we can
see that
the number of shares trading on amc in
the first 15 minutes of this week are
already bigger than what we had on
friday bigger than what we had on
thursday tuesday
and last monday as well so only
wednesday was trading more
we got for now we are testing the 22
level but this is looking good guys this
is looking good i think we're going to
push 225 today uh so i like what is
happening here
okay
i'm gonna try to find
okay this is a nice pattern that is
forming we just miss a clear
consolidation that can help us to find
um
[Music]
where the supports are okay as you can
see here we have a breakout but this
trend line has one two three four
reactions but no reactions in the very
recent past so i'm not sure the suppose
this 20 the support is that 21 or a
little bit below
we are
going through the 22 levels guys right
now
so this is very good
okay h1mc is pushing higher
as well so here once again i'm going to
come back to amc and jimmy very soon
um but
what i'm monitoring on hymc which is a
golden silver miner so we're going to
have a look at gold very soon i'm going
to show you what can happen there and of
course
um this is very much related to uh the
reason why amc decided to get some shots
of hymc they are playing uh you know
this big
these big moves up that we can see on uh
the commodity market and that is gonna
probably last for some time so
um
so i think that we are at in a situation
where we just entered the bull market on
the community uh prices i mean commit
this market for the coming
one two maybe five years so this is the
reason why everything that is related to
these commodities so it can be oil it
can be gold it can be silver
is i think um
you know there is a lot of interest in
the stocks because they have a lot a lot
of potential so we're going to discuss
that very soon i'm going to show you the
chart
of this commodity prices and i want to
um as well explain why
why everything is going to be um more
expensive i think in the coming
years and what
and what impact it can have on the
economy okay
so bam bam bam jme going through the 160
level guys very interesting
let's have a look at the volume
okay so same thing
nice volume so it's very good to see
that
nice volume as you can see it's the
biggest 15 minutes volume we had a part
of the one we had on wednesday so it's a
nice impulse it's giving you
very strong signal to the market
okay so what we would like to see here
is a move really beyond this wedge upper
band that is right now acting as
resistance as you can see
um
we
got
we found some
you know resistance just here guys at
164.
so closer to 200 day moving average
um close to this 160 level close to this
wedge upper band so we can see this is
where things
are happening here so once again
if we want to go beyond this level we
really need a lot of volume but for now
uh the volume is here on the 15 minutes
time frame so let's see if we have more
room to push higher uh here
okay and then
hi guys so
ask me questions if you know if you want
and um
i have prepared a lot of things i want
to go with you through today
so we can discuss
we can discuss um
let's quickly have a look at bitcoin
because i think that bitcoin then i'm
gonna talk about the global market once
again i'm gonna come back to this um
[Music]
situation that we have on hymc so this
is related to the community market
so first bitcoin guys uh i think you
were with me when we had this breakout
above 43 000
last week
so it happened on thursday
um
it was a breakout above this
trend line so once again let me quickly
recap the situation on bitcoin
so it's quite interesting
to see what we're having right now
we were
we were moving down for the past uh
three months okay we had a sharp move
down then we moved sideways for one or
two months and we were creating this
nice
triangle pattern
that is um that can be used to know if
the market is about to shift on the
upside or on the downside whenever we
have a breakout for the breakout to be
good quality it needs to happen with
volume and here
it reminds me a little bit the situation
we had here look at that case
okay
so for now it is actually hard to say
if this breakout is gonna be is gonna
hold or not
and as you can see back in the back in
the time here in june 21
uh so it was
one year ago roughly a little bit less
than that we had the same kind of
pattern we had a strong move down uh
then we had a triangle pattern and a
breakout above the upper band of this
triangle as you can see here
okay
and we had a strong move it was a move
of ten percent higher then it was
followed by another move of four percent
higher so we we had bitcoin that was
holding um that hold basically three
four days above this triangle upper band
and as you can see
it has moved through this level without
volume here we have a little volume
increase
okay
but
it was not a big volume which means that
everybody was not in this trade and then
it goes it got sold out okay so this is
one situation that happened in june 21.
then as you can see we had a little bit
again the same situation
here i can draw
uh
another triangle
okay
and this one
so happen one month after that
and it started exactly the same way as
right now we had this breakout above the
strangle upper band that started first
without volume okay and we grounded
higher
without volume make moving roughly by
two three percent a day uh but without
without strong volume and then suddenly
the volume appeared where did it appear
it appeared close to the recent highs
which means that bears were there and
that uh this is when a lot of bitcoin
needed to be exchanged for bears to be
defeated and whenever we had the signal
then we had a pullback that you can see
here that happened between
uh
39 and 37 so around six percent lower
and then we moved
strongly higher so this was the signal
that bulls took back control on the
medium term even long term so here in
this we are a little bit in the same
situation so for now
of course it looks bullish
but we didn't test the major levels yet
as you can see
this breakout first above 43 000 which
was the first signal that we are moving
higher
occurred with very low volume okay
so for now it it's not giving us really
the information of uh
did the bears let it go and will
everybody get in bitcoin or not yet and
for now the answer is no for now people
are waiting there is not a lot of volume
that is trading once again bitcoin is
trading on different exchanges so we
need to check that on all of them but i
have done that and there is no exchange
where i saw a big volume increase
happening during this breakout so this
is telling me
that
we still need to wait for more
information bam
to really know if we are able to go to
to make new highs you know to go back to
the 60 60 70 000 area you know close to
the recent highs um
so for now once again
the volume is weak even after we went
through 46 000 which was the first
resistance area so we could expect that
we need some volume to go through this
level but once again we went through
this level as you can see on low volume
it was here the volume trading
yesterday when we go when we went
through the 46 000 level
was even lower than the one that we
traded when we went through 43 000. so
um
so this is telling me once again that
for now we don't have the big
information i need to see a very strong
volume training and then it will confirm
of course not with a hundred percent
triability but with a high probability
that bulls took back control and
whenever we see that then same thing as
uh
as usual
we can use a lot of different uh tools
for example fib ratios we can use
moving averages a lot of different
indicators to find where the support
levels and where the second wave
pullback could happen okay so for now
we don't have this information so we can
very well just get rejected brutally and
make new laws this is still possible for
now it's not looking like that at all
but it is still possible we have some
major resistance that is to me around 48
000
okay
so look amc
ripping
above the 22 levels so we have here some
nice situation that is happening you we
can see that this is the major
resistance right now it's a little bit
the equivalent level of 160 165 on gme
so both stocks are for now um you know
finding some resistance at this levels
once again we're gonna monitor if we're
able to see a very strong volume
happening
here
so on a 15 minute time frame once again
this
was already good information to see that
the first 15 minutes of the day were
trading on higher volume than every day
last week except one which was wednesday
where we moved really really strongly
higher
okay
so still
for now
look at that we are coming at the wedge
upper band
again
okay it's like mc wants to go to 25
so this would be
what i'm talking about
and there is a lot of room we have a lot
of room
above look at that we are breaking out
above 22.
so gm is following of course those two
are moving together but amc is
today
making the nicer moves for now
okay so let's go back quickly to the
cryptocurrency market so like i said
uh we are looking very nice but we for
now the volume we
went through some resistances uh like 46
and 43 without volume so this is not
where uh the big money players were the
whales on the crypto market
48 000 is the next resistance level so i
think that 48 500 even let's be precise
so i think that to go through this level
we would need at some point to involve
some volume um and if we see this volume
coming then the pullbacks that will
happen probably later will be very very
good to buy so we're going to monitor
that
and see
if this scenario can happen
let's go quickly on ethereum so it's a
little bit the same situation so as you
can see
you can draw the same kind of patterns
because those two assets are of course
very much very correlated uh and here i
see a little bit the same thing
okay which is that we are moving higher
we are taking back some important levels
but
uh to me the
real resistance levels have not been
taken yet okay so ethereum it's around
three three thousand
four hundred okay
the 200-day moving average that 3 500 so
this is where we can see
um
the real resistance
levels that uh
that can
i think um
need a lot of volume
to be taken back so let's see what's
gonna happen here
for now we are bullish but we are
waiting for the confirmation of this
are you hearing my discord okay sorry
guys
and
indeed okay i was on mute bam let me
handle that
is this one okay i know because i have
one here all right
okay should be better sorry about that
guys thanks for letting me know
okay so
what do we have
so still jimmy for now
finding some resistance
at this 200-day moving average
as you can see this is where we went
so we are testing this area
once again to go through these levels we
need a lot of volume so if we are able
to do that
guys
we would be in a very nice situation so
we're gonna monitor that once again amc
is moving today a little bit more than
jimmy
and here
okay it's quite interesting
what is happening
let's analyze a little bit the situation
was shorter term
okay it's it looks very much to me like
we are doing a fifth wave here of this
first move up
okay
this is once again
high volume very impulsive so um usually
whenever we have this kind of strong
moves that go through some important
resistance levels here we are 22 and we
had this um
this downward sloping trend line
and we went through that with volume
this is looking to me like the beginning
of something and uh it looks like the
beginning of this fifth wave that can
once again go i think to 25 so let's see
if we're able to do that today this
would be once again a massive move up
um
it's going to be interesting let's have
a look guys at what information we get
from
uh the option market okay so i was
checking hymc we're going to get back to
that very soon let's check amc
and yeah okay nasdaq i'm gonna show you
guys what is happening there
but once again we have some
i think
good information that can be um
used for amc and jme that is coming from
the global market that is coming once
again from the vix that i'm that i'm
keeping an eye on uh bitcoin is going as
well together with that we are basically
right now bullish on everything yes we
are bullish on amc uh on me i mean on
meme stocks on the global market and on
the crypto market but as i said
um
you know every move to be healthy needs
at some point to take some uh rest some
pose so i think that we still have maybe
one two or maybe even three days ahead
of us that are gonna be um you know
controlled by bulls but then at some
point we're gonna need to pull back a
little bit so i'm gonna show you the
different scenarios
uh bam bam bam so
what is happening here
let me refresh that
okay that's growing
okay so we have the expiry of the 25th
of march
so we lost some options that were very
out of the money options and that we're
creating
um
a maximum synthetic
short
of 15 no it's not that bad
actually so you see everything has been
rolled roughly because all the options
we lost on the 15th on the 25th of march
expiry are back already so this is very
good information
the dtc is at 2.9 okay
because okay there is so you can see
shots
have added to the position we were at
19.7 of
uh regular shot interest rate we are
right now at 20.3 so this is the data uh
once again coming from 15th of march
so basically this is rather stable i
would say
and the synthetic short is increasing
because retail is buying call options
maybe only not only retail by the way
but we have a lot of options that are
both
uh
rather close to the money for now
but
this is looking good and the dtc is at
2.9 so once again we are coming to the
areas where
uh big things happened in the past okay
as you can see in november when we
almost squeezed we had a dtc at 3 3.5 so
we are just below this levels so it's
going to start to be very complicated
for shorts to hold
this short position if
we keep moving higher so we are coming
to the scenario where
you know we can just squeeze
so as you can see right now we keep
pushing higher so this is very good
okay
let me have a look at uh triple q bam
bam bam so
this is a little bit the situation that
we are in
and once again
this is i think related to what's gonna
happen on you know the rest of the
market
so i mean crypto market and meme stocks
i think this is um
you know
all related of course
so here we were in a correction okay and
the question we're having is is this
behind us can we be bullish again um you
know on the medium term at least for the
coming month maybe even years on the
global market
and my answer is that on the short term
like i said we are looking good uh we
have some good signals because we trade
uh we took back the 350 level that was
for me the major level to take back for
this correction to be complete at least
um this was the first signal
but uh
this is not enough the major resistance
area is to me at 370 so slightly above
just like for bitcoin just like for a
lot of stocks
and
um my scenario my preferred scenario
from here
is that we keep you know grounding
higher
and because i don't see any reason we
don't really go test this level so we
have here once again the 200-day moving
average that is coming at 368. we have
this 370 level that is created by the
recent highs by some recent lows um we
had a lot of volume that was trading
there so this is uh to me the major
level to take back
four
bulls to be really in control i don't
think we're gonna see that happening
right away i think that right now we
entered um you know a consolidation area
where we're gonna have lower volume
lower volatility uh the market is i
think gonna stabilize a little bit in
this range so 370 350 because those are
our closest resistance levels and
support levels so right now i think the
market is looking for a direction and
usually when the market is looking for a
direction uh you know it starts to
oscillate to be ranging so this is what
we can expect to happen i think on
triple q
uh spy is gonna be the same thing
so um at 370 i think that we're gonna
have a rejection so when could this
happen i think
around the 5th of april once again this
is very visual but it's you know giving
good information
so around 370 we're probably going to
have a first rejection and then you know
we're going to stay in this range and
depending on what the market is giving
us depending on the news you guys know
that we are in a situation that is a bit
difficult to handle for
the fed regarding the inflation um
regarding the the rates that they need
you know to increase to target inflation
but in the same time they need to uh
manage to to keep a good environment for
the economy to uh keep developing for
the um
labor market to stay strong
for the growth to be here even in a
situation where we have a war where
business is not easy to make across the
world you know because of all the supply
chain supply chain issues that we can
have because of this as well community
market prices that are just going higher
so we're in a difficult situation and
for now we don't have all the answers
about that so as long as we don't have
all the answers i think it's going to be
hard
for investors to really be bullish on
the long term once again on the short
term we are buddhist there is no doubt
about that
but i think that we need to see more
in terms of press action and in terms of
news to really turn bullish on the long
term for now i have two scenarios
uh in both of them we are just you know
staying in this range for one or two
months okay so i think that
the market is just going to be quiet the
global market
look at that guys pam pam pam's amc up
15
okay so we are going to 25 it's pretty
obvious right now
okay jimmy going through these levels
guys
so
right now we can just you know observe
because there is no more resistance
so it's gonna be it can become very wide
okay
we went through this wedge upper band as
you can see
so right now we can even act as support
we can maybe find some you know uh
support at 160 that has just been taken
with volume
uh so to me this is a clear breakout
so let's see what can happen here
we can see that the spread between amc
and gme is tightening we were trading at
21 premium this morning we are now at 18
and
we are even
more than that
okay we're at 14
very interesting situation
okay so um
so my view on the global market once
again is that we're gonna keep
developing sideways for the for the
coming maybe month
uh with not a lot of volume
um the moves are going to be uh smaller
so we are waiting for the vix as well to
give us the signal that you know things
are really calm
and that you know boos can start to
think about
uh building long-term positions which
for now i don't think is happening yet
uh i think we have buyers but
um
i don't think it's like really
trades that are done on the long term
it's more like short-term trading for
now
uh and if the vix is coming back below
20 once again which is the level below
which we can consider
that the fear is gone of the market for
now there is still fear vixen 21.4 is
not um
you know it's not a vix that is telling
us that we are in a
easy environment where things are just
going to go one way here just telling us
that
moving sideways with sometimes some
strong moves is a very likely scenario
um so once again my view
on triple q spy it's going to be a
little bit the same thing
is that we keep grounding higher so spy
the level is 460 and then at some point
we find some um you know we consolidate
we move sideways the vix is gonna
probably be close to the 20 area at that
time and then there's gonna be the
question that we all uh i i mean we're
gonna have the answer of the question we
all have which is are we gonna be able
to go through this 370 level on uh
triple two and 460 roughly on spy with
volume okay it's going to be important
because right now we can expect the
volume that keeps decreasing okay
because we're in a situation where you
know investors trade less a lot of
investors and wait and see mode so we
can expect the volume that keeps
grounding lower with this market that is
you know
stabilizing consolidating here and then
either we go through 370 with the volume
increase
or
through
350 okay so on the downside and this
information that for now we don't have
it so we can of course try to guess but
i mean it's not very relevant it's
better to wait for the price action to
give us information uh either it's below
350 and then it's not looking good it
means we had some bad news it means that
inflation probably is um you know just
moving higher and it's hard to control
that the growth is getting impacted by
the war
uh and that the fed cannot do anything
anymore to tackle that because they need
to keep the rates at high levels to
control inflation this is the narrative
they have so they are stuck in that so
we just need to hope that
those higher rates will not impact the
growth too much
um
as well as the war so this is the
question we are having for now it is
very hard to answer
um the best answer we have is the answer
that's coming from the market that is
once again here telling us we are
bullish
on the short term but we are waiting for
some long term signals
okay guys
okay so i have some question is amc
running more because of the difference
in premium example that you were talking
about
um
it's hard to answer
but once again
i think that
a lot of investors have seen that uh amc
is late the reason why amc is late is
like we have seen
the massive number of options that we
had on 25th of march expiry on jme
this expiry is behind us so right now
i don't see any more reason for this
for this premium to stay here uh once
again this big gamma that we are on 25th
of march expiry um
created a lot of short position short
exposure on
on the option market maker side
now
they probably still had some short today
because the experience on friday
they probably still running a little bit
after the price
to try to you know um
to
buy those shares that
they are short
but right now
i think it's gonna just regularize the
the so amc will probably catch up this
week on this spread we
in the past have checked sometimes the
spread is staying for you know a couple
of weeks two three weeks for now it's
been one week so we can still have jimmy
training at a premium with so right now
17 18 compared to emc
um but at some point it's gonna come
back to the normal levels but once again
it's only gonna come back to normal
levels when things are gonna um a little
bit
stabilized so for now we are still in
this strong impulse strong first uh move
up that hap that started you know two
weeks ago
so
it can stabilize a little bit during
this move up but most likely we would
need to wait for the market to take a
pause for the second wave pullback that
once again is gonna be i think uh the
very very nice opportunity
uh to
you know build up some long position
uh using options because right now
options are still crazy expensive
and
depending on where we are pulling back
but most likely a collapsion that if i
mean waiting two weeks plus the
volatility going lower
is gonna impact any option price that is
around the 30 40 50 levels 50 strikes by
50 okay so it's it has a huge impact
time and volatility has a huge impact on
options so this is the reason why the
best timing to buy those options is
whenever you see a strong move up that
is clearly you know the beginning of
something like we're having right now
um
and to wait for the strong move up to be
finished so it can last once again one
more day one more week i don't know
i think that 25 needs to be touched on
amc for this first impulse to be maybe
complete uh maybe we need to go higher
it's once again here uh very hard to say
uh we can only you know try to guess but
we need
really to wait for this uh high to be
you know um hit
and then
then we're gonna see once again lower
volume lower volatility lower momentum
and this is going to be our second wave
that we are waiting for to
uh to build up some position
so
dme
you know
still looking good
staying at this 160 165 level
this is looking great
hymc once again as well we're going to
keep an eye on this one guys because i
mean
the focus is on mcgme of course
but this is a very small market cap
and
if amc is doing well
i think the it's going to impact as well
hymc so uh the
resistance level that i see is around
250 so for now we are below that so we
can you know i mean it's a real gamble
uh to know what's going to happen here
but um
but i want to show you something guys
i want to show you something so we're
going to have a look right now at uh the
oil market the oil markets is i think
today dropping a little bit
bam bam bam
okay
and you're gonna see i'm gonna show you
something about the oil then i'm gonna
show you something about gold that is
related to oil uh and
and then
i'm gonna show you why i think hymc can
you know break this resistance and do
some nice moves and we're gonna discuss
quickly targets
even if it's early it's still good to
have you know a rough idea of what we
can expect
[Music]
jimmy 280 end of week
yes why not
why not 280 seems a bit
a bit far from now but given
once again the strong volume the strong
you know bullish momentum that is
creating here
it's possible
but first we need to go through this
major resistance area
with volume to defeat the bands that are
sitting here and then the next real
resistance level we can start to talk
about that to me is 250
okay
so if we're able to go through that
i mean
here we would need to make a massive
move up we really need a lot of volume
to go through this levels
um
i'm not sure we can make it without
taking your pose
but
as we can see in the past sometimes you
know those moves are very very wide and
very strong so it is of course possible
another information we can get
that's interesting because once again
when you measure one plus three so once
again elliot waves uh on the short term
worked very well on amc ng in the past
so this is the reason why uh i'm still
using this
methods here especially when it starts
to move exponentially and like i said
whenever we measure one plus three so
here are my first
four waves
then we can apply fib ratios to one plus
three to try to guess where the fifth
wave might go and
i told you that the 61.8 percent is uh
the most you know likely level whenever
the third wave is extended
uh but the 1.618
is
the one that we usually see if we have a
fixed wave extension so in the very
bullish case
we could have a first wave that goes to
250 uh so it could happen this week
um
[Music]
so it's hard to say what can trigger
that but i would say that if we go if we
move through this resistance area today
that is once again around 160 170 if we
go through this resistance area with
volume so volume is here for now um
then we could very well be in this
scenario that
is
um
giving us a target
around the
250 levels so you can see the 1.618
level is at 247
and the recent high
that we have
in this triangle is at 250 so we have a
double
level here so i know it's looking very
far from now um
but we can still you know just try to
imagine
what could happen so it's a 50 move up
it's not that much guys for a stock like
a gme uh 50 is not
crazy we can look in the past
you know
it was moves of 100
20
okay
so the first squeeze is i think a little
bit different because because no one was
prepared for that uh what we are having
right now is a situation that is more
for me under control
by both sides everybody knows what can
happen
um the options are well priced the
volatility is very very high so that
option market makers have protection uh
so that they can you know take the time
to react uh they are not gonna find
themselves you know trapped like they
were i think back
back in time
in june in may and in jan
let's see let's see i
i doubt that we can do that without a
pause
to be honest
but once again if we are able to go
through these levels and close around
the you know 170 level today this
becomes
a scenario that can very well happen so
let's see if we're able to do that
it's going to be interesting to follow
so once again nasdaq not moving what not
moving much
okay amc
still looking very good i think we're
going we're going to 25. uh i was
discussing guys about uh
the oil okay
woohoo dropping heavily today
all right so we got rejected at 115
level
okay we still have support around
i would say 90 97
95 the 9500 area is an area of support
so we maybe we're going there
so we're gonna need to see but whatever
happens this is what i wanted to show
you guys we are here talking long term
all right uh on the global market like i
said i think we have you know
a boring month that is coming ahead of
us i think that not much is going to
happen and that in a month or maybe even
two months we're gonna have a direction
that is going to taken be taken either
above 370 or triple q or 460 on spy or
below uh 440 on sp y and 350 on triple q
okay
but something that has already happened
and that has already taken a direction
and that is going to be for long term is
the oil okay
and
of course the oil is the commodities of
commodities i mean the raw material of
the raw materials which means that we
need oil to produce anything even to
produce uh steel even to mine you know
gold i mean everything
that um everything requires uh this
first energy to um
to work so
whenever we see that this breakout that
here occurred uh you know very clearly
with volume increase uh
with the consideration before for for
some fundamental reasons above 97 and
yeah 1995
we can expect
that this move up
is just the beginning of something that
can last once again we were talking here
about a 10 year move
uh so we are breaking out above the
resistance that was created by 10 year
uh correction even if it was a sideways
correction with steel corrections i
think that the oil market is entering
um you know a new era
so this is a little bit scary because we
might see things that we've never seen
before
um
it's gonna have a huge impact once again
on the other communities so that's why
i'm going to talk about oil and
ultimately i'm going to come back to
hymc and i think this is the reason why
adam aaron decided to take some shares
into the stock
um
so yeah this is a long-term move we have
95 97 92 you know this is the support
area i think we're going to stay above
that i'm not sure what's going to happen
in the coming months maybe we're going
to you know just oscillate here
um but what i think is that
at some point we're gonna have you know
a strong move up and we're gonna revisit
the recent highs and who knows maybe
even go uh beyond that
so
what
impact can this have
first
on the rest of the communities and then
on the market so let's try to answer
this question
so if we have um a look you know at all
i mean
i was discussing a lot of energy stocks
with you guys
um and they all have a little bit this
kind of shape okay so i can show you i'm
gonna beat you for example
okay
so here we're talking it's 2018 so it's
maybe not the best example but
you know uh b2 is an
energy stock and it broke out above
20 in fab
uh retested this area and now he's
moving higher so i think you know we
we're going to keep moving higher and
you know have a lot of stocks like this
one and this is just showing me that the
whole energy market
is seeing
on many stocks some clean breakouts
above some
some resistances that were created by
long-term uh
trends long term usually down trends so
this is once again confirming to me that
we entered a new era on the energy
we kind of felt that but technical
analysis is here kind of confirming this
feeling with
some facts that are breakouts volume
and yeah pretty much that
so
what impact can this have on the gold
market the gold market has a different
shape as you can see
all right so i'm here on the weekly time
frame
so
thank you very much
um
all right so it's forming a kind of huge
cap and handle okay
i'm here on a weekly time frame
having a look at gold all right guys so
gold is so today losing one percent
uh okay
so
first
i want to just
use the fundamental reason that i just
gave you on the energies energy prices
so oil
a lot of stocks gas
and
once again remind you that this is going
to impact
the rest of the community so we have a
fundamental reason to think that
um
that everything is just gonna go higher
so right now we can do some technical
analysis and trying to um you know guess
what could happen on this market so oil
uh gold sorry
uh is seeing you know has seen a very
strong move up happening street since
two or eighteen okay and then uh the
march
here this was the kobe crisis so we're
at the bottom of this fourth wave then
we have a massive rally and things just
you know were more calm and since
uh
feb 22 so last month
we have a breakout above this trend line
that was very nice we bought here by the
way for those who are with us in this
code we posted an alert about that
um
and we had this breakout that is to me
the beginning of a fifth wave right
and this fifth fifth wave
is probably going to go through this
you know trendline that is here and if
it happens we would have a valid
cap
and handle pattern
okay that is here quite obvious so for
now we don't have this breakout but my
take is that we're gonna break out once
again because of what i'm seeing on
the oil market which is to me uh done i
mean i don't see any
unless we have some really fundamental
reasons that change i don't see how the
oil market rally can stop so i know this
is going to impact the rest of the
communities and this is the reason why
here i don't have the breakout but
um you know i kind of feel it's going to
happen and if it happens
as usual break out re-test and then
we're gonna push higher so we can expect
you know
gold to be trading around 2500
uh maybe by the end
maybe next year you know in a year a
year and a half okay this is gonna be to
me
maybe then the end of this strong move
up so then we're gonna see what's gonna
happen
but this is giving us
okay a move up on the gold market of 20
30 okay this is what we can expect
silver as you guys know is moving
together with gold and especially
um we have discussed that before already
so i'm not going to show you everything
again but we've seen that silver is
trading
um
i mean gold is trading with a premium
compared to silver so silver is going to
follow that move and even probably
amplify that just like just exactly like
amc is doing today compared to gme i
told you guys that amc was a little bit
late and we can see it's catching up
today amc up 15 gm is six percent so we
have
uh nine percent catch up
so it's pretty
pretty strong
[Music]
bam bam bam
okay
so we can expect the same thing to
happen between gold and silver once
again the spread is going to tighten at
some point
it's going to probably take some time
but all of that to say guys that we are
bullish on the energy so we are bullish
on um
on the rest of the community market we
can see we have some short-term uh
signals on gold and silver we don't have
the long-term signals yet but uh my take
is that it's gonna happen maybe in a
month or two let's see
so
let's go back to what we're discussing
at the beginning of this video hymc so
uh both gabrielle and i have bought some
shells so i did it at the open with you
guys
uh gabriel did it as well
so um the reason why once again is that
there is this interest into the stock
which is creating this bullish momentum
but there are some fundamental reasons
like i've just shown you to believe that
in the long term
uh everything that is related to
you know
gold silver mining commodity
uh
is gonna do good
all right so i'm not sure about how this
company is managed probably not very
good because
they would they would not be dropping
that heavily otherwise
but
if there is new money coming if there
are some good decisions that are taken
if the gold and silver prices
uh enter a rally that is gonna last that
we've seen probably one or two years
maybe even more we're gonna see
um
it's gonna be much easier for these
companies to make money right
so
for now we don't have a breakout above
250
but once again my take is that this
breakout is very possible
that um
it can happen
if it happens what can we expect okay
guys so let's have a look at that
hey paula hey bro thanks
okay
i'm gonna answer the questions soon
what is the next big resistance it's 25
on amc
uh
why do i have 25 i'm gonna get back to
that i think i need to go in the shorter
term because right now i'm having 25 but
it's not that obvious
i think i use fibs and i used um
previous highs and lows
let me just conclude on the targets that
we can have on hymc because once again
we have some volume coming
we have some breakouts that might arrive
soon we are trading above the 200 day
moving average for the first time i mean
for the first time
for the second time okay let's be
precise
since
september 20
so this is already some good information
about a reversal that might be coming
so if we're able to make this breakout
then as usual
we usually find some resistance around
the recent highs
and then you know we go from one to the
other so the first one would be at 3 30
and the next one at 570.
so of course we can go higher but then
it would we would need to have a lot of
um you know positive news about the
company
but 330 570 are levels that might be
reached let's quickly have a look at the
option market on hymc
okay we're gonna monitor that because
once again if we see that things are
getting hot
this is gonna be good information
alright
why is my price delayed
okay so it's training at 180.
bam
so we have some short interest
like i said we checked that at the
beginning of the video there are a lot
of shares that are getting emitted so
it's not easy to um you know find um i
mean to to use the short interest data
like it is because
um
we are using different
data that are not updated on the same
day but what is important is that we
have some short interest and then we
have uh some options that are getting
both
so let's see which strikes are getting
both here
and we have options until the eighth
strike
so for now
those options are concentrated around
the three levels
so it's showing us investors are bullish
but for now this is not going to create
too much trouble for option market
makers so we're going to monitor that
and we're going to see if
the other strikes are growing or not if
they are growing once again this is
gonna tell us uh
you give us information about how likely
we are to make very strong moves
okay so
for now we are looking good here as well
mcc is still going higher
so let me quickly have a look at your
questions guys
so amc running because of the difference
okay
jimmy 280 so let's see i think that 250
is possible 280 seams are very i mean
high of course but i don't see any real
resistance around 280
but 250 why not once again
for the 250 scenario to gain weight we
would need to
cross the major resistance area which we
are
testing today right now around 160 165
with volume so let's move into that
let's see if we're able to do that
so won't amc be stopped by the 100-day
moving average
bam bam bam the 100-day moving average
and i'm not paying much much attention
to this one it's not a moving average
the
moving average that i personally use
but whenever you switch time frame uh
it's
pretty much comes back to the same thing
as uh
changing moving averages so 100 day
moving average but on which time frame
bro this is what
sorry i lost
your questions once again give me a sec
once again guys i lost my window let me
reopen it
okay
i'm back so
so 100 day moving average but which time
frame because i guess on the daily time
frame
so let me add it quickly i'm going to
change the 50 to the 100
and let's see if it has acted well as
you know support or resistance in the
past and if yes then it can be used of
course all right so i'm saying it's on
the daily time frame
so look um
i mean
you can try to
you know
have a look at it by yourself
brother
okay so who asked me that luik
um
i don't know i don't see this 100 day
moving average really well respected in
the past
uh look the last time it was crossing
the press action was in november
and okay yes
we had some reactions okay fair enough
we had two support reactions
here resistance so yeah it has acted
indeed a little bit and even here maybe
but it's never touched perfectly here it
has not been touched perfectly here it
has not been touched perfectly uh here
as well so
i'm not saying this is not a resistance
i'm just saying that in the past this is
not where traders were located i mean
this is not what traders were taking
profits and this is not where traders
were buying so maybe things gonna change
but most likely uh this is not a strong
resistance okay so this level is at 24.5
uh so let's zoom in a little bit because
once again i showed you that my
resistance is at 25.5
pump
i would rather put it at 26 when i look
at it once again the way i um what i'm
what i'm doing to find the resistance
levels i'm checking at the previous uh
highs previous lows and some levels
where we had a lot of volume so as you
can see
here we have a big volume bar when we
went
through this 26 level why 26 how i know
it happened at 26 and not 25 or 27 it's
because i have some i had some recent
highs here at 26 and some recent lows
here at 26.
so if i put myself back in time
and
i'm seeing here a huge volume
as you can see it's the biggest four
hours volume we had
going through
from 23 to 29
i know that this volume was created by
bears that were at 26 and that got
defeated
because at that time this was the
clear
residence level created once again by
the very recent highs and very recent
lows and we had five reactions so it's
good enough
then we can see if this level acted as
resistance or support in the future so
here we go through it
uh is the volume increasing when we go
through it or not
a little bit not amazingly but we still
had some bulls here and then here as you
can see it was clearly it acted clearly
as resistance
uh on very low volume by the way but
the price action got rejected at 26 and
then we moved lower so for now
this is the immediate
uh
resistance level that i can see
and
the other method that we can use now
that would we have one plus three is to
measure one plus three and to apply to
the bottom of the force wave okay
so this
is not giving me very precise levels
here
okay
so once again i'm checking at the sixty
one point eight percent the one to one
and the one to one point six one eight
so it's giving me 24
23.8
27 and 33.
so fibs are giving me three different
levels and then the i'm using trend
lines uh to you know find the real
resistances and for me
the resistance area is around 26
so maybe we're going to push a little
bit higher it's not easy to say we don't
have enough press action here trading in
the very recent past to really give us
precise levels so what i'm giving you
guys here is not very precise but it is
i think good enough
uh
to me the first resistance level is at
26.
okay
okay so ding ding dong
not very happy no offense
okay
uh so you're asking a good question i i
said that we didn't that i don't see the
price action really making uh
you know a squeeze between before
so i was talking about april may june
okay
once again i can remind you why i was
saying that
and let's see if
uh things have changed or
okay so if i take amc chart we're going
to do that on both of them
i was saying at the time we're trading
around 14
20
and i was saying that i see the price
action keeping moving sideways until we
meet this major resistance line that is
created by this triangle upper band
that is right now around 32 but that in
april you know june
will be
you know moving lower so i was saying
that as long as i don't see a breakout
above this level
i don't think we can really squeeze for
now as you can see we have a first
impulse so it's good okay it's very good
news
but uh if we look at what is happening
on the rest of the market
um we have some strong resistance
happening here at 370.
um this is true for bitcoin this is true
for uh triple q
and we are still in an environment where
um
even if you know the bullish sentiment
is clearly coming back in the past two
weeks uh on the medium term long term we
are not fully bullish yet and we need
some fundamental reasons to you know for
this to happen and once again as long as
we're not very bullish on the global
market asset managers big money players
they're gonna be cautious with where
they put their money they're not gonna
you know because they are they're not
making big profits on their long
positions so you know they're just not
gonna put um
you know money in risky assets
uh heavily
right away they will do that
progressively uh little by little
but
um so yeah this is you know my global
view so for now we're looking good but
we don't have the signals that things
are really
um
you know
that all the problems are behind us then
can we squeeze in this environment i
mean a squeeze is an event that is
by definition
almost unpredictable but what we can say
is that for now
uh
if this is happening so i don't know
let's assume the first scenario i was
discussing this morning so amc moves to
25 okay when i look at it
closer it's rather 26 okay the level to
watch
we can of course go to 32 right away
it's possible as well but whatever
happens i think that's at some point we
need to consolidate
uh we're gonna have a second wave put
back so in the very bullish case amc
goes to 2d
uh two right away
in this case we can try to
see where the second waveform that could
be
okay and it could be around 25. so even
in this case
in the very bullish case
uh
we might see the 25 level again
maybe
you know
here so mid-april
so in two weeks something like that
uh and then we might take you know
one more week
to go through this 32 level so in this
very bullish case
um
i think that's
end of april maybe beginning of may uh
we would have this third wave
okay uh third wave move up once again
third waves are the ones that
uh you know involve the biggest volume
involve the bigger smooths as you can
see the volume is big right but look at
what it was before this is the volume we
had on wednesday
so we had
a very big volume 117 million shares
exchanged but as you can see
this is very small compared to what it
can be okay
it can go to you know here in may we had
700 million shares exchanged in jan we
had 400 million shares exchanged and in
may it was for many days in a row so
what i'm saying is that of course
um
of course this is good of course this is
very positive
but it's
not
yet
i think uh
the
big big moves we're gonna see those big
moves once again usually occur in third
waves
so um and the third wave occurs after a
second wave so for now i didn't see the
second wave
uh so maybe it's going to be all
different you know that's possible i'm
just checking the past and trying to you
know imagine what it can be if the same
um
you know structure is forming and as you
can see even in any
kind of squeeze we had in the past there
always was a second wave pullback do you
see the second wave pull back here
because
okay we can try to you know
to see
i don't i don't know here it's not the
second we've come back we have only
green candles okay so maybe this time
it's gonna be different maybe
but most likely it's gonna be
a little bit the same kind of structure
so we always have one or two red candles
in any move up okay for the market to
breath and for now we didn't have them
once we're gonna have it and then when
we're gonna go when we're gonna start to
move higher again
then
i think that
you know
the really really really
big moves can happen so once again uh
let's see and as you guys know you know
technical analysis is not
anything that gives you very
exact levels exact timing it is just
something that you can use to
try to anticipate what can be the market
structure where are the support levels
where are the resistance levels um you
know what the price action is giving us
in terms of momentum
uh things like that guys so yeah
this is
pretty much what you can expect here
okay do you think we'll head back to the
may 25th gap of 10 wolf no
i don't believe that i don't believe
that because the move we're having here
is impulsive enough
for
the bullish momentum to be taken back so
once again just the same way as when we
had the breakout below 38 i was saying
we need time and i started to talk about
april may
june i'm not sure i mentioned june but
probably i did if dim dong dong is
saying that
um
and for the the reason why was because
we had a major breakout with volume that
was breaking that was you know just uh
changing the momentum here we have the
same thing that happened on the way up
and this move up is gonna leave a memory
in every bear's mind and they're gonna
be buyers at lower levels they're gonna
you know try to uh reduce the positions
at
uh at
levels that
they're gonna consider as good because
they lost a lot of money in this move up
so this
here once again is very impulsive i
wanted i was telling you guys last week
that i wanted to see um
amc moving in five waves up that we
didn't have it we had it on gme but we
didn't have it on amc now we have it on
on amc clearly uh we're having a
beautiful fifth wave that is forming
right now that once again i think is
going to 26.
um
of course it can go higher but 26 is a
level that makes sense to me once again
i explain why because we had volume
training across this level and that this
was the um
natural
support and then resistance level in uh
like a few months ago
uh bam bam bam yes amc it's crazy like
up 18
jamie up eight percent so we are having
uh the catch up i was talking about guys
so it's beautiful to see happening live
uh jimmy's a little bit stuck at this
165 level
uh bears are here let's see if we have
volume if we have volume training on gme
it's good news it means that you know
the selling orders are getting consumed
and that
bulls are working on it all right so
we have volume guys we have volumes so
you know this is not
this is just a consolidation
and
you know the market wants to push higher
but definitely bears are here i don't
know how many shares they have
but
look at this volume exchanged
okay let's go on hourly guys because you
can see that
this volume is not only 15 minutes bam
second biggest volume and look this
candle is very small right
usually you have big volume whenever you
have big candles whenever you have big
moves because you go through a lot of
levels and you accumulate i mean there
are a lot of
shares that have been exchanged on the
way up or way down here way up but this
situation is different
we have a big volume second biggest
volume on the hourly timeframe and the
hour is not finished guys we have four
minutes left four more minutes um
that is training
with the move that is not moving much
what is this telling us this is telling
us that
uh
that there is you know
a wall of orders like a ceiling all
right that is created by sending orders
and that disorders are getting consumed
all right so once again we don't know
how many of them they are but once
they're all going to get consumed
then it can uh you know there is nothing
that can stop the price action to move
higher i mean
um maybe we have some bears of 170
but most likely they are all here
and it's pretty obvious today what is
happening
um
you see there is a very strong buying
power on both amc and gme
but gme has reached the level
where
i mean this is the major
bear camp that i was talking about last
week
we are there we are at the uh we are
here on this bear camp we are in the
bear camp so there is a huge fight right
now between buus and bears
um
once again if the battle is won
let's try to find other levels
okay
we have 180 we could go
brutally to 180 it's possible
it's possible because i can see the
pressure that is put by bulls here in
this area is very very strong why is it
very very strong because uh we are
really you know
uh in
in direct contact with this resistance
non-stop okay and consuming the selling
orders
so uh
this is
looking strong and
once again i don't know how many orders
there are but at some point they're
gonna be consumed and once they are pop
then
it can just explode all right let's have
a look at the rest vixx is moving a
little bit higher no plus two no
okay i have here plus two now vx is
moving lower no okay it's still up two
percent but it's moving lower during the
day it opened a little bit higher but
it's moving lower
nasdaq still bullish guys
okay so this is looking good
look at amc guys
look at that
going going there we're going to 20 25.9
let's see if this resistance area is
going to be
well respected
let's see what's going to happen
but this is absolutely massive
the catch-up is happening right now in
front of our eyes guys
so then the question is is amc going to
pull back or is jimmy gonna break the
ceiling of those selling orders
good question it's hard to say
okay
h3mc is still doing good
okay jimmy updates
pam pam
why victor rcc
my bro from
alexis where i was working happy to see
you brother
okay so what else can we see
uh
okay
so bitcoin is still like close to this
levels
okay guys so
we can look at so bb-8 cat
okay
we're gonna keep an eye of course on
what is happening on amc jme guys
okay so
we can have a look at the stocks that uh
were doing good last week but that were
a bit stuck so we're talking about bbig
we're talking about mullen so let's have
a look at that
okay so
okay
so a bit weak today but i'm not
surprised because as you guys know
uh the flows that attract that are
attracted in amc and gme are actually
um
you know coming from the other meme
stocks okay and everybody is today you
know focused on those two hymc is to me
related to emc this is going together
um
but bbig and you know milan i i haven't
checked mullen yet but i'm pretty
i'm guessing it's you know not moving
much or even moving lower as well
so
bbig is just you know moving a little
bit lower still above the streamline
that is acting as support as you can see
for the past six trading days so a
little bit more than a week
so
we can expect this
support to hold
but once again i don't know we had a lot
of fake signals here i don't have any
strong view on bbig
um
i don't think the focus is here for now
the volumes were just you know we had
one big volume day and then volume lower
lower lower
so um
280 is a level where you know
something can be done because it's the
lower band of the gap up we have here
uh it's the previous high that we had
here we had some
you know support as well in jan
so this level is i think a support level
but not very strong
uh
so either we just you know fade like we
we used to
before or we find some uh bulls sitting
here and we have the volume coming back
so it's gonna it's not easy to to trade
honestly
uh because
i mean the best trade to be done here is
just to buy here with a stop loss below
250 something like that but i would
personally not get in because once again
uh this is not where the flows are right
now so i don't think this is the best
place to put uh your money um
so yeah i don't have a strong view here
i think that the interest is not here
for now maybe if amc and jamie are
pulling back then bbig can move up again
you know we're gonna have some maybe
profit taking on amc and then the flows
would get back here
this is a scenario that could happen
um
so we will see guys we will see what's
going to happen
right
then chi cat fisel okay i'm gonna have a
look at that guys
for now i'm still keeping an eye on him
seeing jimmy it's very interesting to
see
all right what's gonna happen because
gme can also give us leading
information about amc
if gm is breaking out strongly above
this 165 level
as amc is late once again compared to
gme even after this catch up we have
today
let's see what is the premium
of those two
okay 12 guys so you can see 11 even
percent
so
we definitely had
a catch-up today
but we've seen this spread at five
percent last week so i think that we
still have
five seven percent
uh
to
tighten between amc and jamie spread so
we're gonna monitor that
uh but the scenario could be that
that amc goes to 26 and that jamie stays
here i think this is a good scenario for
day
that would make sense in terms of um
you know things that come back to normal
a little bit
in the spread
and
there would both be
you know at the resistance levels
uh at the first resistance levels we
have here okay
the only thing that
is not looking
so obvious to me
is that dme major resistance is 160 165
but amc one
is rather 100 is rather 32 guys so
can amc go to 32 today
i don't know
maybe
okay it's beautiful guys
okay so i'm gonna have a look at ticket
i'm gonna have a look at fisan
so how do you know if the pullback is
over on jimmy and emc so first i have no
way to know for sure but i will just uh
try to
use fibs okay
uh to know when the pullback is over so
for now we are still you know just
moving higher so there is no reason to
think a pullback will happen for now
this is very strong so we can
keep moving higher uh
as long as you know we have this
uh moves that happen with higher
momentum and higher volume so this is
the case for now
um
but once we know how high how high we're
going to go we can use fib so let's say
we go to 26
which is i think what is happening right
now on amc
then the pullback will probably occur
around 21. the 38.2 percent which is the
first support that we're having here so
the 22 support i can get rid of it it's
not a strong support
so um
you know once again if you see strong
volumes happening on the way down so of
course for now it's not at all what is
happening we're moving strongly higher
but at some point you know there's going
to be a pose i think
and then
um
and then we need to see how big are the
volumes on the way down if they're
happening very on very low volume if we
move lower but with no volume
then usually the pullbacks are very
shallow okay so when they're shallow it
can be usually the 38.2 percent so 21.
so i think that going to 26
you know doing like that maybe here
trying a little bit more to push then
move a little bit lower
okay this is a possible scenario all
right so sorry up
okay let's say we are bullish so once
again
i think
it can go faster of course
but
maybe april end of april
is when this could happen okay
and
it's interesting to see that the 100 day
moving average is acting as resistance
right now so let's see
i don't think it's a strong resistance
so i don't think it's gonna hold very
long i think we're just gonna consume
quickly the orders that are sitting here
uh i don't see it anymore if i do that
oh right so
um i'm keeping an eye on that and i'm
gonna answer your question so bbsg it's
done then ticket
okay
not very bullish because we had a strong
volume
uh and then the next day
it just got sold and no one was here to
buy that
no one was here to buy that
pullback so on ck8c we are not in a
situation where
the momentum is shifting we are in a
situation where bruce did an attempt to
go through this levels
so the levels
the level the resistance level is
270. so bulls tried to go through this
level but as you can see
in one day
they got
you know brutally rejected all right and
the next day
uh they didn't do anything they just
waited here
so um
they didn't buy
um so i'm not saying we're not gonna go
back to it but i'm just saying that this
is not looking uh very bullish
okay i'm checking the past
it's in the past we've done that many
times consolidating here and then we
always had a downside breakout so maybe
things are going to change now maybe now
the breakouts are going to happen
on the upside i don't know
but for now i don't see any
anything very different from what we had
in december what around in jan so i'm
waiting to see at least a close above
this blue trend line
so um
i think that
if we are able to close at 270 to 80
even three would be better then
something could happen let me add that
in my watch list
uh i've been in the tkt trade before
i use the stop loss i got stopped on
this
so i don't have a good memory you know
so whenever i don't have a good memory
about a stack i usually
i need really to see some strong signals
to get back at it
okay
we're gonna then check the opportunities
we can have today guys once again as you
know i'm keeping a track of everything
that looks interesting to me so i'm
adding tickets which doesn't mean that i
will get into it but i will keep an eye
on it so we said 280 all right
sorry
okay
so this is going to give us an alert
whenever ticket reached 280. all right
fisell fisel
we know already so i didn't check this
out today but we fisa is in the list
we are monitoring it
and the level papa look at that guys
amazing amc going through this hundred
day moving average
um not very surprised it's not a strong
resistance
let's see what's going to happen around
26. i think this is
where we're gonna have a fight
the next fight
okay
hymc is doing good as well
oh right so
fisell
okay so it's good i like to see that i
mean sometimes
i know you guys prefer to see strong
moves up all right you prefer to see a
massive rally with a big volume and then
everybody is getting interests and
you know
and some
investors just consider this as a good
trading signal i don't what i consider
as a good tuning signal is whenever i
have exactly what is happening right now
with fisano so whenever i have a clear
resistance line that is created at the
beginning by only two levels two points
okay so one
two and as you can see here i have
adjusted my trendline because if i
really use the highs i'm going to be
here all right
but then as you can see we have here a
consolidation that is forming a
consolidation is forming whenever we
have multiple reactions in a short
period of time on a level and it's
forming around the 200-day moving
average and around this 2690 resistance
level so then i have my trend line that
is here
coming um
you know from
the highs
that is not
coming on this consideration so i adjust
it all right and here i miss this
okay but i don't care
because what is important is the recent
past i know that this is where uh the
battle is happening okay and i'm i i
want to
uh know who is going to win this battle
so that is going to give me a direction
and the reason why i like to have this
consideration lasting long is that it's
making clear where the bears are and
here it's now very clear that they are
located
around the 690 level so this is
happening on low volume it's good if you
have high volume in this consideration
uh periods then you know it's just
creating usually noise you have big
candles and you don't see clearly we
like to see uh really small moves small
volume uh pam amc at
25 guys
so
okay it's catching up i told you guys
this premium between amc and gme is not
going to last long it's going to
regularize soon and
it is all right right now we have
okay nine percent spread only so we can
assume the spread
once again last week we saw six we can
assume the spread to be at uh
you know eight percent
to be at five percent something like
that then things are going to stabilize
i believe
okay and like i said once again look
look
what i used to build the spread i used
okay 120 21 okay
i use those two levels as i used 130 gme
is equivalent to 21 on amc
so we can expect guys that let's see
it's not done yet for now we're pushing
higher but the scenario that is starting
to uh
to be built
is
is that this first wave will go to hunt
226
and then maybe the pullback
will start happening for now i know it
seems
you know maybe
um
not intuitive to talk about pullbacks
because we are pushing higher but i'm
already trying to anticipate where we
can have this because i want to know
where this uh which level we could reach
after pullback
because this is where
it's going to be kind of easier to trade
okay
emc at 25 papa
okay so let's go back to fiscal and so
here we're gonna monitor this breakout
so once again
uh either if we have the breakout during
the day then it's good to
um
you know enter at the close but it's a
little bit risky because you didn't have
the big volume that usually training at
the close that is sometimes completely
changing uh the price action
uh
levels
but if you wait the next day for the
output let's say we have a move official
that is closing at seven
and you don't buy
before the close the next day sometimes
the pre-market is going to be at 7 20 7
30 right because everybody is going to
be okay we have the breakout let's buy
so that's why the best thing is to
to to
trade before the close but
you need to be careful
uh
that you know the breakout really really
occurs whenever you get your shares
okay bam guys look at that amc 25.3 it's
just you know unstoppable
uh
okay
how high can it go i think 26 is the
next uh level we're gonna see a fight
happening so we're gonna see that live
guest together we're gonna see if okay
it's coming i think i need to stay on
this chart
it's gonna happen now guys
massive massive move up of amc
jimmy's following
all right so we're going to keep an eye
on that of course
okay so
this fissile is done
one what do you think when amc hits the
target of fifth wave uh are you talking
about the short term or long term
about short term i think that whenever
the fixed wave is hit we're gonna have
you know
uh a consolidation first
happening just below so a first
rejection then come back to it you know
and here consider it just a little bit
like we've done here
uh we might see some
first
short-term reversal
indicators that are gonna start to
appear once once again with lower volume
momentum starting to shift down things
like that for now we don't have it
uh we i don't think we can have a
rejection
just that happens right away uh once
again after some strong moves like that
the market always need to digest what is
happening and it
it's very likely gonna you know just
uh stay around the this resistance line
okay just like gme is doing with the 160
165 level it's just as you can see
hovering around this level even if it's
trading high volume
um the price action is just staying
there so no i don't think we can see a
strong rejection i think that even today
we cannot really
uh if we go to 26 i don't think we can
really close much much below than that
because the bulls are putting a very
strong pressure and it's it's gonna take
maybe one or two days too slow and we're
gonna we're gonna have some signals that
are gonna start to appear that are gonna
tell us uh that the momentum is slowly
shifting uh towards bears for now it's
not the case at all volume is big uh the
moves are strong
um
so let's see let's see what's going to
happen here
hymc of course is moving higher
so
okay
so
amc touched
25.73 it's getting rejected
a little bit the first time
uh i think we're gonna get back at it
soon
let's see
you know
the usual process of
whenever the price action comes to
resistance is that it's testing in it's
testing it multiple times on the short
time frame so that's why i zoomed in i'm
right now in a 15 minutes time frame i
can't even go in a five minute time
frame if you if you want to have you
know a really
a closer look at what is happening
around this level
uh bam a lot of volume trading here so
you can see
here
amc took a lot of volume
it's the biggest five minutes volume
that was training almost during the week
uh so booze are intensifying their
um they're buying orders
so for this reason once again i think
that they are still located everywhere
here buying pullbacks okay
so we're gonna probably
go there again at 25 26
so let's see
okay
so oil market once again
where is it
uh yeah i wanted to discuss as well
quickly
that
i'm not sure you guys are very
interested in what is happening in japan
but it's pretty interesting to see the
usd gpu that is absolutely like ripping
for the past week and the reason behind
is
that the policy used by um
the
bank of japan which is the equivalent of
the fed
is very very aggressive basically those
guys they are you know buying the 10
years
yields
uh they are buying i mean the bonds to
tackle inflation i mean they don't have
the same inflation issues uh but their
monetary easing is uh
you know very very
strong because they go even to the next
level by buying those bonds whereas for
example in the u.s if the fed wants to
have an impact on the long-term yields
which is ultimately having an impact on
inflation
they only move the short-term uh
rates right in japan they go directly on
the market and they buy
yields they buy bonds so
this of course is sending a very strong
signal to the market that
we have divergence in the monetary
policy between japan and the united
states and that the
japan is going to keep you know um
increasing injecting money in the
economy because once again when the bank
of japan is buying they're buying with
money uh that is created all right so
this is the reason why the jpy just gets
hammered and the usd jpy is going to the
sky so we are coming close to the 125
level which is the first resistance
level on the usd jpy but given what is
happening
my take is that we revisit the highs
that we saw in 2000 uh so around 135
okay so for those who are interested a
bit about uh the japanese yen i know
some of you uh are not interested in
that at all so i'm gonna be quick
uh but we might have a first rejection
around 125 level then go through it
re-test and then go to 135
by you know next year so i think that
this rally is once again not just a
random move up is the beginning of uh a
long-term move and as you can see you
know we have one move up one move then a
strong correction and i think we we're
gonna see things on every market that we
haven't seen for quite some time bam bam
bam look at that guys
amc came back at it
right away up 27
that's no joke
that's very very
strong so now we have touched
25 points
we are right now at 26. so let's see
what's gonna happen
uh let's see if this is indeed a
resistance area or not that's i showed
you guys how we found this morning
uh so we're gonna monitor that
right now we're staying here on amc
charts
five minutes time frame we can even go
guys if we want to
you know be really close to the action
we can go on a one minute time frame
and look guys a lot of volume training
but the price action not moving a lot so
this is
we're going through it
are we able
if we go through it right now
and we are we are
this is guys
okay
are we able to go can we go to 32 today
okay let's see this is maybe just it's
it's i'm only one minute time frame so
of course it's very volatile and for now
we need to hold a little bit longer than
that above 26 to consider that uh bears
have been defeated maybe here you know
they hesitate him but
they're gonna you know sell
more shares i don't know
uh
amc up 30 guys that's very very very
serious and
guys this is
i mean
i'm trying to see
what information you can get from that
okay biggest five minute volume ever
so this is once again showing you guys
that it's just bulls are
extremely extremely strong because
uh these 26 levels
gave us i mean
we stayed 10 minutes
below that we got rejected once it was
at 25.73
we didn't even pull back and then we
went right through it so of course a
five minute time frame is not a time
frame that can be used
for uh breakout so i'm not sure
this signal is valid or not yet but
just like we did with 22 this morning
where was it it was here
we went through it we tested and then we
moved strongly higher so this is very
possible that
we go through 26
we just retest it quickly and we go
right away to 132 gme is coming close
guys to
uh this 172 level it it's breaking guys
it's breaking out above the 160 level i
mean
so what information can we get here
the 200-day moving average is being
crushed okay
for now we don't have the information on
the daily volume which is of course
going to be important but we already
have a very good idea that the volume
trading today is going to be one of the
biggest we've seen
uh probably bigger than even the one we
had on wednesday let's see but as you
can see we started today with a very
strong volume slightly lower than the
volume we had on wednesday but the next
volume bar
is bigger than the first one we had at
the open today so the sum of those two
is almost equal to what we had on
wednesday and this one that is right now
uh trading is also
uh is going to be huge guys it's going
to be huge uh so we
we are looking of course very very good
guys
okay
so bears still fighting guys
now we're gonna
we're gonna see
we're gonna see live
okay
who can win this battle
but for now we have some rejection but
once again it's not
um
for now we don't have
i mean a very good information because
we
got rejected select it below we ran
through it we don't know if you're
retesting it if we're getting a little
bit rejected i think we're gonna stay
around this level for a little bit of
time
okay
triple q fading i'm keeping an eye on
the when on the rest of the market it's
a very isolated move
that we're having right now on amc ngme
the rest of the market is not you know
doing anything crazy
uh we've seen
so bitcoin break broke out yesterday
above 46 000 wednesday above 43 today is
very stable i mean strong but stable
we don't have big volume i'm checking a
little bit
what else is hot
and nothing else is hot guys we only
have amc and jme that are extremely hot
this is where the flows are going today
can we go to 32 guys can we do that
today
that would be
really really nice
okay
we are
a little bit consolidating around this
26 level for now
which is totally normal
uh we had a lot of volume trading here
the biggest five minutes volume was
trading
uh
trading today traded right now around
26.
okay we have the biggest volume
since
even the 23rd of march yes today is
going to be a historical
volume trading probably
bigger than the one we had
in august and let's see if we can get
close to the volumes we had in may
but definitely this is nice guys
okay
then then
look at this rsi
at 87 and bulls keeping pushing
that's nice
okay guys
look at that the negative beta i told
you again that this is one of the signs
that we want to see
is the market um you know training
negative a little bit and
jamie and amc
going higher because this is the
environment we were in when we had those
massive moves up happening
uh you know back in may back in jan
and today we have spy down 30 bips
triple q that is that up in the day
quite good but that is as well moving a
little bit lower
we have amc up thirty percent
jimmy up 15 14
right now
jamie going through
its major resistance level guys
so
we still need to stay cautious but guys
this is looking very good
okay
i'm staying guys here on this chart
because i really want to
to see
as close as i can what is happening
around this 26 level
definitely a huge fight
a lot of volatility as you can see it's
not exactly 26 it's like we went up to
26.5 almost
we are now
you know a little bit rejected but
definitely guys there is there are a lot
a lot of buyers
here
okay we are not even coming to the 20
period moving average on the five
minutes time frame so this is showing
you how strong this move is
okay getting a little bit rejected right
now but once again i'm not really
worried
uh
probably gonna
it's gonna be bought quickly
but at least what is very very good
today guys that's a bit it's truly of
course to
uh
you know
make some
scenario with price targets for the very
long i mean
for this potential squeeze that is
happening right now but what we can
already
say
uh and those are facts
okay and then we're gonna see how we can
use those facts
to predict
uh
you know as good as we can what can
happen next
is that
we had the most impulsive move we've
seen since
may okay that's a fact this move took
back some major levels
that told us already last week that the
correction
looks like is over we wanted to see
for
this
bullish momentum to really be strong we
wanted to see five waves okay and this
morning we didn't have it yet
and i was telling you that uh even if we
have lower volume lower volatility and
lower momentum it is totally acceptable
because the market was making lower
highs okay just like here then we went
through this level
it didn't give any opportunity to um
you know to increase the position with a
pullback this move is very strong but
it's
uh must
i mean very often happening like that
um
it's very hard to get in those strong
moves when whenever they start it's
better to you know use a consolidation
area that is more calm uh where you know
it's easier to trade to build up some
positions
um so right now we had this fifth wave
up
so
um
so what we can say
and this is a fact
is that we
had an impulsive move with the biggest
volume we've seen in almost a year was
the biggest volatility we've seen in
almost a year that took back some major
levels and that developed in five waves
so this is uh
what i call the first wave so once again
i don't know if the first wave is
complete or not
uh maybe we're going to go to 32 today
uh 25 was the target we discussed this
morning
uh i i mean i was having 25.5 then i
adjusted it to 26 by looking at the
previous highs and lows that we had
that we had before i don't know if
those who are watching right now
uh were here at the time but the way we
found 26 is that we checked here
the
big volume that traded through
the
previous resistance or support lines i'm
not going to do that again but when he
did when we did that analysis this
morning
we saw that 26
just because of this day was a huge
volume and this resistance the support
the support and this resistance uh was
the level that could
uh give us
you know
a target a reasonable target
i like to say reasonable target when we
talk about 30 move up but uh i mean
there is no big
uh surprise and of course it's
uh always
a bit surprising but a 30 move up that
is happening after uh those strong moves
we we saw last week is not something
that is
um really unexpected that is uh really
surprising both bulls or bears
so for me for now we're having a kind of
i would say
well structured price action
that reached the 26 target
so right now
maybe we're gonna push higher once again
uh fibs are only giving
areas and
26 was not
inside those levels okay
we had 34
sorry
i'm not at the bottom of the force okay
we had uh
24 27 and 33 okay so it's hard to say
this fifth wave which level it can go to
and we've seen that 26 is the first
natural resistance okay so we said that
maybe this is going to be the end of the
first wave if this is the case
because right now we are having a very
impulsive move that is telling us once
again whenever we have this kind of
moves the market remembers it and
it's very likely
that
after pullback consideration small
correction
uh we have a third wave that should be
stronger than this first wave okay
because third waves are when really big
money players are getting in massively
for now we have some early
players that put big money already
but
it's not once again the big volumes
we've seen in the past
because whenever
we check what happened
in may
here
i mean look at those volumes guys
we feel like the volumes are strong
right
but we need to keep in mind that this is
only
i don't know 20 of what amc can do okay
so we we have still a lot of players
that are waiting that didn't get in the
trade okay whenever the rules are big of
course there are a lot of buy and sell
um
trades that are that are done in the
same day in the same day
but
there are also a lot of
buyers that just accumulate shares
and of course this is what we need for
the price action to really really move
strongly higher
so for now the volumes are big but it
can be much bigger so what i'm saying is
just that once again not sure this first
wave is complete or not
um
26 has been reached we discussed this
this morning let's make two scenarios
we're gonna make a scenario
where this first wave is complete
and we're gonna try to know
where
the pullbacks can happen because now
everybody is doing that okay everybody
is wondering where can i buy some amc
shares
and
the first level that comes is 38.2 which
is uh i would say the most
common level for second waves
uh
it's a shallow level so
for 32 for the 38.2 level to be reached
and nothing beyond
we want to see low volume during this
pullback now can they pull back how
would
what kind of shape can this pullback
take
we can check at the past
okay
we can check at the past and we can see
that before
second waves last
one two three four days okay for may we
had four days to get in some shares
before
it was too late
i think
the same situation is about to happen i
think we're gonna have right now a
window of a couple of days
that is not starting today that is gonna
start whenever we're gonna have
uh
the first real rejection for now this is
not a rejection this is just i mean it's
a rejection in the five minutes time
frame it's not a daily time frame
rejection
whenever we're gonna see that
then we have probably a window of
between two and four days
here it was three
and here it was
two okay so between two and four days
where
um
it's gonna look
like
amc is rejected actually it's just gonna
be
um i think a little pose before the real
move up once again it can also fade on
the downside we need to be prepared for
everything but i think it's a risk that
is worth taking
and
if
we go higher of course this level would
be higher but the same thing can be done
now let's check
we have only two
situations where we can compare
we can check quickly what happened in
november but let's be honest you can see
guys that what is happening right now is
very different from what happened in
november
uh because of the massive volume and
massive moves
in november even here we moved strongly
higher we had one day okay one big
pullback day
and
how much retracement was it oh we can
check what was the fib ratio that was
hit
during this second wave pullback so it's
hard to say if the first wave starts
here or here
i would start it here because this is
one move
okay so you see in may
the
second wave pullback went to the
uh between 38.2 and 50
off
the first move up if i take a larger
move up it's still 28.2
so for now it would be around 21 on amc
so i know
it might seem maybe uh bearish but it's
not bearish it's bullish okay we if we
have a pullback to the 21 area in the
coming in in the next couple days
uh
to me
it is just
giving us the energy we need for the and
the players that are waiting below
because if we keep moving higher
some buyers they will just not get in
the trade because they are waiting for
an opportunity to get in lower
if we go lower we can get those buyers
in the trade and of course we need them
we need everybody in the trade for
uh you know those strong volume to
happen through the major resistance
levels because
um
as you see whenever we arrive at the
resistance we have a fight and we need
volume because we need to consume all
the selling orders
and to have volume we need everybody
that both in the past to buy again okay
so let's see for now we're getting a
little bit rejected from the 26 level
which is let's be honest not very
surprising but
we don't want to get rejected too hard
okay for this day to be a good day it is
already a good day but to be the perfect
day
uh
to be the perfect day let's be honest it
would be even better we go to 32.
and consolidate then around 25 but
going to 26 is maybe even better because
we would be able to buy shares at a
better price next week or this week
let's see when
um
yeah so i want you to check that so here
we went to 38.2
the second wave went there
last week
uh sorry
last may not last week
we have another one that we can check i
don't know if it's really comparable
okay because it was the first time it
happened
and we only moved by 25
higher
before pulling back and this pullback
went to the 50
um
retracement feed retracement
um
okay i wanna do three four five i'm
gonna
i'm just trying to check all the
pullbacks that happened on amc
before strong moves up okay here we have
an interesting army even here you see
even here
so i measured the move from two to three
so we have a sixty percent move up so
roughly similar to what we're having
right now
and uh
i measure that and i check fibs and i
see that
even in the smooth we retrace to the
38.2 retracement level exactly before
the massive first
squeeze we had in gen 21 okay
so of course things can be different
this time
but i think that we're going to see this
38.2 level again so
21.2 if
uh if the if the high of the first wave
has been hit today
okay let's check jamie let's do the same
thing
and let's see james
is ahead again okay
guys
the problem with this breakout but we're
talking about stocks that you know
which behavior is very different from
the usual stocks okay we know that
but
so this breakout is good to have uh i'm
in the breakout above the 160 level and
above the 200-day moving average
but
i would like to have more consolidation
before that is showing me that
we had this period of balance between
booze and bears that gives energy to the
price action and that allows
um
you know a lot of players to get in the
trade here things go very fast
which is good as well
um
okay
i will measure things i'm just checking
you know it's possible as well that
i'm wondering can we just
squeeze
right away
you know it's because we have some
little considerations
okay
so we can check
at the past it's the best we can do
bam
so
okay guys and yes
hit that like button thank you bro
give me some love guys
i'm gonna stay here with you
updating you with what i'm seeing live
on amcgme
of course those two stocks as you know
they are very unique and
you know going through the price action
of those stocks is you know
tricky
there are a lot of traps
but we have already
you know
some data that we can use
to make
some assumptions about
how
the players that are involved in this
trade are acting and i wanted to check
second wave pulls
pullbacks okay on amc and gme because
this is what we're waiting for we're
waiting for the second wave pullback
uh to get in
and by motions i think that many many
traders are doing that right now
and so we need to be slightly ahead of
them
and we also need to be
not sure because you can never be sure
but to have good reasons to think that
the pullback we could see that is not
happening yet
uh
is not
looking like a strong rejection okay
because if yes
then
uh it can be more
i mean deeper than the 38.2 percent but
first
let's have a look at gme and take the
last moves up okay
and bam here i have a one
okay so you see here we went to the 50
retracement
back in september 20.
you see even in this strong move up
there's always
you know some
you know candles red candles here
okay this for example is extremely
shallow
and but this guys i remind you this was
the first squeeze nobody was ready to
see that no one knew how to handle the
situations uh every trader was just
shocked but what but what was happening
uh so i think that right now things
would not happen exactly like that but
let's check even in here
uh and the situation is very different
because as you can see
here we were in an environment where
so this was back in 2020 gen 21 we're in
the environment we were moving higher
and you know the market was
breathing each time here it took a
breath here it took a breath
okay so this is not a second wave
pullback but i can still measure that
50 percent okay the market was breathing
breathing breathing and then suddenly
started to really move
to accelerate
and even in this acceleration
we saw
the 38.2 level i know no no no it was
not reached okay so here between
23.6 and 38.2
so i'm just trying to find the levels
that we can use not to miss this move
okay
okay
we can very well
i'm wondering what would happen if we go
right away to 250
because right now we are
above the 160 165 level
uh we didn't get rejected here we were
having
a weaker momentum at the end of last
last week
this is not the case anymore
so
bam
okay on the hourly time frame we still
have those bearish divergences that are
drawing
okay
we have mixed signals let's be honest
this transaction is very hard to analyze
i'm having mixed signals because i'm
having a wedge upper band breakout above
160 i'm having a breakout on the daily
timeframe above 16 165 but on the hourly
time frame
i can see the momentum is a little bit
failing but on higher volume so most of
information i have is of course very
bullish
um
and i'm just trying to know if
we are
i mean if this first move up is complete
or not
and if this market
needs to breath to go higher or can he
do it right away and for now
i see we have energy guys i see we have
energy
sorry this is a machine
let's see what we can do today but a
move
okay up let's use the regular scale
150
116 is all i mean i don't think we can
really go below that right now
i was talking about 130 this morning
right now i think that 130 is a bit too
far
okay
ah okay maybe we go to 180
180 is the breakout level we had in
december 21. it's a level where we had
i'm trying to find the target for this
first wave okay
and of course it can go to 180 250
uh 165 i was saying this morning but now
this is broken and with increasing
volume so
it doesn't look like
the end of the first move up for now
it's not looking like that
amc is pulling back a little bit but
this is still strong
um
and yeah 180
once again let's analyze a little bit
what can happen okay so this is the
breakout
level we had
back in december 21.
uh
bam bam bam
is it higher
yeah 181
here we had a big volume chaining but it
was higher so the volume is not helping
us much here to find the next resistance
level
um it's very wild guys it's not easy i
don't know
i don't know
i mean you know i always try to give you
some levels where potentially we might
find some
you know sellers or buyers
on amc i gave you 26. it seems
that indeed we had some sellers located
there right now we are
correcting a little bit
but on gme
i gave you 160 165 we went through it
strongly today
right now i don't see clearly i have the
next resistance at 180 and then 250 okay
that's all i can say
um
for me we didn't pull back at all
here so i'm expecting at some point a
pullback to happen
but the pullback will not happen
if booze are so strong so for now
uh
we are more likely to push higher than
pullback
okay this is what i'm seeing
cool brother i hope to see that you
enjoy that guys
okay
okay
thank you very much guys i'm happy to
see that
you learn things this is what i'm trying
to do with you
once again i'm not taking the easiest
talks guys to analyze but you know you
decide what you want to see right you
want to see mcgme i want to
give you you know the best content on
the stocks you like so i'm trying to use
the methods i've been using for years on
those two stocks it's of course very
challenging uh the situation is
different but you have some um
techniques that work exactly the same
okay everything that is involving volume
you know volume is just an indicator
that
you know can be used everywhere
and the resistance support areas as well
uh fibs as well i think they're giving
me good information the difference
between what i'm used to do
which is basically trading stocks
that are
i mean respecting
better the
price action kind of rules all right
with the
pullbacks and everything
i mostly trade
big caps you know when i was working
in banking i was mostly even trading
futures uh to be very
um
you know clear
and
and so yeah this is a different game
but
we can see that a lot of methods still
apply to the stocks
and
right now for example 26 has been
acting as resistance so let's see what
can happen from here
okay i'm keeping an eye on everything
else guys we have nasdaq that just came
back to flash
spy little bit lower
amc back to 25
i think we're gonna you know just go
back to 26 oscillate between 25 and 26
um
okay i have some questions about options
so
options guys we keep an eye on that of
course
so options look bullish guys so let me
go back to amc
but
i don't know if you remember but for
some of those who watched my videos for
some time
um
to me we still have a lot of room games
so
we have a little room on the volume we
still have the situation about the
global market that is not clear to me
it's not a perfect bullish environment
and regarding the option market so the
regular shot is very very stable guys
for the past year
always between you know 18
and 20 percent
uh as you can see here
so here i'm only having data since
august 21
but you can see the regular shot is
actually increasing guys okay so shorts
ad are adding
and it's funny because they are adding
on the way down
all right fair enough
um what i'm seeing very different
compared to what we had
back in time back in may back in jan
is the maximum synthetic short so the
maximum synthetic short is
created by out of the money options that
i bought
mostly by retail investors okay those
very high strike that
i think guys it's not good to buy
of course is there if there is a massive
squeeze you're gonna make money with it
but you can make money with lower
strikes like
40
um 30 seems a bit low right now with amc
at 25 but 30 40 50 strikes you can make
as much money if we go to 100 150
then the 100 strike and
most likely
um
if we go only to another 50 60 which is
possible which is a very nice price for
mc
but not close to the squeeze targets the
lowest strike
uh will allow you to lock in some nice
profits whereas the very out of the
money options
will expire worthless so that's the
reason why
i believe that it's better to go to
lower strikes okay even if you have a
little bit less leverage it's still
better
better monitoring of course what is
happening on those very out of the money
strikes like the 145 strike and i don't
know if you guys remember we had 20
million shares before on the strike
and then you know the expiry occurred it
was 10 22 expiry and then i was telling
you guys we need to monitor
whenever
this uh strike is gonna get rolled and
whenever buyers are gonna get back to it
because this is a good indicator of
uh a very strong bullish bullish
sentiment
and right now it was at five million a
couple of um
months ago a couple of weeks weeks right
now it's at eight million so it is
growing but if i take the sum of all
those options okay i have 78 million
equivalent shares
which is representing 15 of the market
capitalization
okay
back in time
we had as you can see here which is this
value that i'm monitoring that is right
now at 15
back
uh before we had
up to 20 22
so what this what this is telling me is
that
we're looking good but we can look
better all right and this is the reason
why i think
that if we have a second wave pullback
um
maybe next week i hope we're gonna have
it because this is gonna be a nice
opportunity maybe we won't have it okay
we need to be prepared for everything
um
if we have it call options are gonna be
cheaper and i think that there's gonna
be a lot a lot of them that are gonna
trade
and we're going to see if from 15
of
you know maximum synthetic shot we can
go to 20 18
20 okay this levels
uh bam bam bam here as you guys know i'm
monitoring this the dtc
so look at that this was the gtc when we
squeezed around 3.5
then it dropped heavily with the price
action and now the price action was here
moving sideways but the dc was building
uh again we are still not close to 3.5
but we are right now at 2.9 today it's
the biggest one we've seen
since uh amc started to drop
some time ago
um
so this is very good news i want to keep
to see this keep going higher
so we're gonna of course money to that
okay let me refresh the information
because as you can see the dtc is
growing with the price action because
the synthetic salt is growing because we
have gamma okay so bam i'm going to use
this information instead of
that one okay bam
okay
ddc 2.95 guys
today so we're getting close to hot
levels
okay so i'm not sure exactly what
all the information i can
give you regarding this option market
just i can tell you that it's a very
animated option market very strong but
was not
uh it's not looking like it was
back in the days when we almost
squeezed and at least uh did those very
very uh strong move up
uh and new highs so for now we are not i
think ready for that but once again if
my scenario which is
uh a second wave pullback close to the
21 22 level
this week or next week
probably gonna which is gonna give us a
window of a couple of days i think
uh where maybe things are gonna be
looking like oh bears are taking back
control no probably not okay we're gonna
need to check the volume once again if
we have a big red day that is trading
more than the green days we had
okay then we're gonna be careful but if
we have a very small volume day trading
even with amc losing five eight percent
uh
it's really not a big deal and probably
it's not going to close the day low
we need to see those moves happening in
today it's even uh stronger
but we're not there yet for now we are
still very bullish
got rejected at 26.
but
i think we're gonna stay close to this
level today
so let's see let's move to that
okay
do you think the top of the fifth
wave can trigger the squeeze
i think that the squeeze can be
triggered in the third wave okay in the
third wave where we're gonna see those
massive massive moves
uh happening with high volume
okay so
once again guys
i'm just giving you here
rough
estimations
but if i look at that
okay let's say the first wave is
complete
okay
the second wave can happen here six of
apple maybe next week
okay
i'm trying to see how steep this can be
if it squeezes it's gonna be very steep
huh we know that guys so
yeah end of apple i think that end of
april is a reasonable target so
i will personally go to options
that are
uh probably june options you know that
seem
pretty fair
maybe it's not gonna happen like that
maybe
you know bears are gonna get the best of
it maybe
but maybe not
and it's a risk that to me is very worth
taking in terms of potential rewards
so here
building a massive
you know position using call options in
the second wave pullback
you know every day a little bit more
we're probably gonna have a three four
days window every day the volatility is
going to be a little bit cheaper every
day the theta which is the decay with
time
is going to be passing so options are
going to be cheaper and accumulating
some options like that
i think is a very good strategy because
the good thing about options is that you
know how much you invest in them not
financial advice once again but
um
[Music]
the loss is limited okay whenever you
buy shares you never know
you know what's the maximum loss you can
have
but buying options whenever we
move like that
i don't think is good
because first usually we see those
levels a couple of days weeks after
with a lower volatility
uh and with time that has passed so
basically option prices between for
example
uh i don't know
last week when we were trading around 20
21
uh if we trade again and 21 into in one
week the difference between the price of
june um options x uh strikes i don't
know 50 is usually you know 50
so i don't know if this happened to you
guys sometimes you buy some options
nothing much happens and you lose half
of your investment
this is exactly the risk here by to buy
options but if you buy options
during a second wave pullback
uh you're actually getting in when
usually you lose 50 if you bought it at
the wrong time so this is the trick with
options once again i've been training
options for
seven years
so
i know this trick
and
and yeah there is of course no guarantee
about anything
but
second wave pullbacks are
the is the right time to buy options
whatever you do whatever you trade
whatever you know assets
uh buying it during the first wave is
usually not a good idea once again
because of the time that plays against
you because when the second wave pulls
back happens you know
time is passing
and it can last one two weeks sometimes
it can seem very long so especially
especially if you you went to very short
uh maturities options
then
sometimes it's just expire worthless and
even if the scenario you think was
could happen is happening but just a
little bit too late
so
what i learned from options is that it's
better to always take a strike it's a
little bit lower than
uh you know basically half of the target
you have so if you have a target here i
don't know 150 options that are around
70 strike is perfect to play this target
with a maturity that is you know a few
months later than when you think it's
gonna happen all right this is
uh i think a good advice that i can give
always extend a little bit the maturity
lower a little bit the strike
because it's gonna uh have it's gonna
work better in the long run
okay
do you think the top of the fifth wave
can trigger the squeeze so like i said i
think the screws can be triggered ah the
top of the fifth wave which is fifth
wave the big one you mean the one that
could go 235
which is my target i think that
so let's imagine the scenario
we pull back
next week or this week uh a lot of
buyers get in we had a massive move up
close to the 60 70 area we
revisit the highs
uh then we're probably going to have a
rejection because it would be dalton
high and then this potential fifth wave
that we're waiting for almost a year
guys
could happen at that time
and
okay what could happen here is let's be
honest
unpredictable
because this would be something that
the usual market players do not
i think take into account
i personally think this is a very
reasonable scenario i don't think this
is crazy
but i think that if it happens maybe for
some players it would be crazy so maybe
they wouldn't have anticipated some
margin calls
some um
you know
loss if there are shorts
or maybe some investors are just gonna
be attracted to the trade and you know
we're gonna have the biggest volume ever
trading on amc you know it's possible
uh
but you know i can't absolutely
you know
give you good information about that
because i of course have no clue about
what would happen in this
new situation but my take is that
most players
anticipate a little bit what is
happening know what are the risks
and they're not going to be surprised if
we go to the 100 level now if we go 235
100 and maybe 50
then i think we would reach some levels
that no one expects can be reached and
then
things
very crazy can happen very crazy and of
course i have no clue about what exactly
but what i think is that
we've seen guys this market is
manipulated
and
we had some examples about
nickel that i gave you guys that
squeezed there was a massive short
squeeze on mikael last week
and we've seen the lme uh exchange which
is the future exchange base in london
cancelling trades that were executed
and making a halt a halt is a classic
thing we know that heart will happen if
amc is squeezing
but how would you feel if they cancel
some trends that go got
executed
you would not feel good right but you
couldn't do anything so this type of
things can happen alright so
i think that
if there is blood on the walls
like we say
that
some big money players get
bankrupt
i think that
the exchange is gonna intervene and save
some of them to avoid a systemic risk
because if some players fall
it can trigger a domino effect that make
other big players fall
some default in payments and ultimately
some risk for banks and for the economy
and the exchanges are of course going to
do whatever they can to avoid that
and i think that if amc squeezes
like reach 100 200 levels
this
kind of things could happen
so i think it's going to be very hard to
trade
and i think there's going to be a lot of
bad things that are going to happen and
that retail investors are not gonna be
the ones that are gonna be
protected i think that the big money
players are gonna get protected as usual
guys so be prepared for that
um
once again i think that at some point
you need to take profit i know that
apes
don't sell
fair enough
i'm just saying that if we go to those
crazy levels we're not going to stay
there long maybe
a few minutes maybe one day i don't know
but
then things are going to get back to
normal and the price action is going to
get rejected so the best thing it's too
early to do that but is to place some
orders
uh everywhere on the way up starting at
100 and going up to 900 i don't know
even if it's very unlikely that we reach
those levels maybe if there is some
trades that are done there because some
buyers need to buy and there is no more
seller if you have an order at 900 maybe
you're going to get
executed but this is what happened on
mikael once again and they canceled the
trades
so what can i say okay it's very hard to
trade very hard to predict
the best thing is that is to hope
that the players that fall so hedge
funds
uh are not putting at risk the entire
economy if they do they're gonna get
protected
okay guys
so i think we're gonna i'm done for
today
um
i hope you enjoyed this live guys
i will do the same thing again tomorrow
we're gonna monitor what is gonna happen
here uh
so for now let me just conclude on what
is happening on amc uh
so amc
moved in five waves with a very big
volume big moves uh
close to the 26th target is getting a
little bit rejected right now but
nothing very uh problematic we expect
the second wave pullback to happen in
the coming days coming weeks let's see
the first wave is not complete we don't
have the signals that the first wave is
complete yet
but usually when we have the signals
it's already a bit late uh for now as
you can see the volume is increasing
the momentum is decreasing but with
increasing volume you guys know that we
don't like to see bearish divergences
but if we have a bearish divergence with
increasing volume
it's fine it's not a bearish signal i
mean it's not a strong bearish signal so
for now i don't have any reason to
believe the first wave is complete
unless
uh that
in terms of ratios and resistance
we
we developed in a classic five-way
five-wave structure so maybe we're gonna
have a second with pullback that is
coming soon maybe it's gonna come later
we're gonna see we can expect 21 to be
reached for the second wave pullback and
if it happens with low volume
and if it's not staying close to 21 too
long
we can expect a massive third wave to
develop
taking back the real resistance level
that is to me at 32 on amc
and on gme guys we are in a very
interesting situation because we
broke out below 160 so maybe this can
trigger some massive moves uh right away
i don't know um
we're looking very good
same thing we developed in five waves on
the upside the fifth wave might be not
complete we can go to 180 that is the
next resistance or 250 that is the one
even before
um whatever happens we would at some
point have a pullback
so it can go it can be much higher if we
go to 250 the pullback will probably be
probably be around 185
if we don't make a new high and we start
to correct right now the pullback would
probably be around 140 level
so we're gonna monitor all of that
uh
and then same thing we can expect a
strong third wave to develop after the
second wave back
so that's it for today yes i hope you
enjoyed this video and if you did please
don't forget to click on this
like button guys give me some love and i
hope you enjoyed that once again and i'm
seeing you tomorrow see you guys
you